what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close i'm geo i'm bart
and today i want to talk about um
something kind of cuny okay it's gonna
be kind of relationshipy um
so i wanna know what your deal breakers
were for finding
a girlfriend
friends
right because they're all deal-breakers
they're all relationships that's true so
like all your relationship deal breakers
so girlfriend
friends
whatever order you want to do it wife
um potential wife
i just want you to brag a little bit
about me
it's okay
um
and uh business partner
wow i'm gonna go on the order of
severity
i love i love the emotionless wow
no that was deep no because i was just
trying to wrack my brain because i'm
like damn no one asked me that before
and you know how like when you go into a
new phase of life you kind of forget
what happened 100 so like the girlfriend
one boyfriend one like
um i think the most
uh
the one that i probably have the
clearest
tabs on
would be problems business yeah because
the most recent thing right yeah for me
i'll go in order of uh
importance or maybe even in the order of
where the epiphanies come from so let's
start with friends
um are you talking about like elementary
school are you talking about like high
school i know because that all changes
for phases right yeah elementary school
i think if you didn't call me names that
was like a very good start
yeah you don't call me names and if you
really liked tetherball or handball
because those were my those were my
things like i was a killer on the
tetherball court the most useless sport
ever because he doesn't go to olympics
and i was like
one with the string yeah it's a ball
it's a string attached to the rope and
what's the point you're supposed to like
wrap it around the pole right yeah you
have to wrap it all the way around the
pole in the other person's direction and
they have to defend it
i don't know if i see that if kids play
that anymore that's might be some like
old-ass [ __ ]
i don't know because i think i also
don't spend my time in like [ __ ]
elementary because that's such a good
hand-eye coordination builder it really
is no you're seeing a ball going and
you're rotating you're moving at a
[ __ ] fast rate yeah and you're
rotating right you're rotating at the
hips
and then uh you you the strategy go up
and down true did you ever hit the
[ __ ] rope on accident
yeah damn in the beginning but i was so
my bad [ __ ]
good
dude i knew all kinds of crazy [ __ ] like
what so like you like like [ __ ]
slices like papa
no that's that's handball i know i just
don't know i didn't know any other
technique other than to [ __ ] smash it
did you ever play tetherball i did i
just all i did was muscle it the whole
way we got to find ourselves an
adult-sized court and i will [ __ ] own
your ass a hundred to zero i feel like
the polls were pretty adult-sized
because they were [ __ ] massive all
right then we'll find ourselves a
kid-sized court and i will
smash you
no [ __ ] you're [ __ ] like 200 pounds
heavier than that so i'll tell you why i
was so good
one of the reasons why i was so good is
i already knew how to serve a lot of
ways
a lot of people how do you serve a lot
of ways exactly so a lot of people they
ask dumb questions like you where they
go what's the other way
i had friends and siblings they're right
[ __ ] that's what happened fine
they would try to serve and just try to
make it fast right because you want the
ball to spin
i knew i was like okay cool depending on
how this guy plays i'm okay this guy's a
blocker so blockers are really good up
top so how i would sir the [ __ ] is a
blocker so you know like once [ __ ] once
it starts going around the pole it gets
faster faster faster fast faster yeah
blockers as soon as it gets like really
fast they're really good at just jumping
up and blocking almost like a volleyball
block so that would they'll block it and
if they're allowed to do that yeah and
when they're really good at that they're
so the really good blockers they'll
block the ball like this like that right
as soon as it hits their forearm and it
spins around they'll time it around and
hit it already so they'll go
boom boom boom and they'll start
generating momentum the other way the
really good blockers are like that i
didn't know you could block wait can we
back up a little bit yeah what are the
rules because all i knew was you hit it
up until it wraps that's you can't do
anything else no the rule is i make mine
defend it i make mine wrapped your way
you make yours wrap my way we can't hit
each other
that's it and yeah and there's a line
like you could hit each other the ball
like i can't kick you in the stomach
that would have made it interesting and
there's lines on the ground i can't get
in your space you can't get in my space
okay dang that's it that's it just two
rules or three everything else goes
everything else goes i don't remember
blogging all right i did smoke a lot of
weeds so
in elementary school
no but that my [ __ ] memories are
[ __ ] i see yeah yeah so if i knew i'm
like okay this guy looks like a blocker
then how i would serve instead of
serving regular i would already serve
down so when you serve down because the
rope goes like this instead of the ball
rotating like this or orbiting like this
it already orbits in a zigzag so what
that causes that person to do is because
the ball is going
high on his back end he starts backing
up to the back because he can no longer
play defense in the front so he has to
go instead of fighting me here he fights
over here as soon as i see him go there
then i even the ball out so now it spins
like
middle so i'm forcing him to use
footwork to battle what the hell that
i'm doing damn i think and what else
what i'm really good at too is you know
when the pole is like this right when
it's wrapping evenly
there's uh way more
uh revolutions
right versus like imagine if the pole is
this big
the string's not that long it might only
revolve maybe once or twice yeah so like
let's say i hit the ball wide
and i see that like this guy's not
paying attention i'll purposely hit the
ball in a crazy angle so now instead of
wrapping the pole like this it wraps the
pole like this so it causes even less
revolution so spin even faster that way
and there's a hook at the top of uh the
pole so sometimes hook
yeah you're right so i'll utilize that
too so sometimes i'll hit it in a way
where it wraps around that hook and you
can't even reach it like i just whack it
and it goes up there okay that's not
fair
what
that's not fair it's all part of it it's
like people are like dunking right it's
like how many friends did you have in
this phase
zero you [ __ ] dirty rat honestly
probably not that much you don't matter
why you were so good because in
elementary school i got kicked out of
two elementary schools you only need one
player to play that honestly yeah
and yeah my mom dropped me off at 6 a.m
so i just practice in the morning until
school started 6 00 a.m yeah what time
did school start
back then probably like seven something
oh that's not too bad yeah but i would
just be there just going home playing by
myself and then i got really really good
so as long as you're good at tetherball
handball it's easy that was a good start
and um non-judgmental people
you understood judgment at that age i
didn't know judgment but i think as a
kid i was very um
i don't even know the word because
you're a kid right but i just feel like
i was very like like open arms like that
and so like with arms wide open with
arms wide open yeah so like let's say
like um
yeah like let's say there's a kid he
looks like he has the stereotypical like
poor shoes or whatever right wasn't that
you that was me too but i would i would
i would never go i like make fun of them
or like still making fun
right isn't that still making fun yeah
but there's also people that are just
like oh that guy's like this they're not
in my group i never really had that
you know i just for me it's just if you
were down to have fun
you're your friend because some people
aren't down to have fun that's true
there's the kids that are like during
recess
they're bringing their homework to
recess doing it like at lunch
interesting yeah there's kids that just
like or like there's kids that like um
like let's say in class right i'm
goofing around in the back like i'm not
supposed to
and then some kids like don't want to
pay attention but they'll still smirk
because what i did was funny and they
like to have fun other kids are like
oh yeah they're not my friends oh you
don't even like to have fun so
that's it so that's my only requirement
was i like to have it matter if you're a
boy or girl because i know in elementary
school also you're just like uh boys ew
no one of the uh
this is kind of sad but one of the um
chicks that i was the closest with
in
elementary school was a girl
what do you mean one of the chicks you
were closest with because i didn't even
see you as a girl i think that's what's
funny so she was one of my best friends
cousins okay and she was so tomboyish
oh right like when we play basketball
you would probably pick her like in the
within your top three choices before you
start picking any of the dudes
that's what she was but because she was
actually had a crush on her but because
she was such one of the dudes that i
felt embarrassed revealing that had a
crush on her
why
i don't know because i think it's just
she's already one of the dudes so i
think it would be i already knew it
would be one of those where like if i
like if i said i liked her then everyone
want to be oh you like her
she's like one of the boys you know
everyone's gonna be like
yeah so i didn't want to say anything
but i had a question though i see okay
then later i find i just lesbian
really yeah or maybe she's spy i don't
know okay what's happening
because i also found out later on uh so
like you know in elementary school like
some some kids go to this junior high so
i go through the other one yeah when i
went to this one and she went to that
one i threw i heard through mutual
friends she had a crush on me
and i was like [ __ ] and you still didn't
make a move well it's too late already
went to different junior highs oh but
you didn't live together because it's a
best friend oh you guys weren't close
okay got it yeah it's just best friend
from school it doesn't necessarily mean
you guys are like neighbors or anything
yeah yeah definitely not it because i
remember i got kicked out of a bunch of
elementary schools so by the time i went
to my elementary school it's the one
across town got it okay you know yes so
she's the one that got away all my
neighbors i did not go to school with
them because they were good kids and
they stayed in the local one got it okay
so now i know your criteria for
elementary school what about you
elementary so what's elementary for you
because i know our time frames are like
our grade system is different so ours
did it the right way and it goes up to
sixth grade
that's [ __ ] weird big-ass kids with
little kids that's [ __ ] weird is not
big yet that's huge seventh graders
putting their kids six fifth and i did
you see pictures of me as a fifth grader
i wasn't a late bloomer like you and i
know but you have hyperthyroidism or
something no i have none of
that um i have elephantitis yes um
no so for me it was k through four
so as soon as you like because in fourth
grade people are barely like one percent
of your class is like hitting puberty
yeah i remember it's really small i
remember coming back from
fifth grade summer into sixth grade it's
gnarly some dude's got deep voices and
you're like
yeah yeah so that's the right way i feel
like
six through eight is good
um and then we went fifth through eight
wow five is puny though
fifth graders are puny yeah
someone that's 10 versus 13. i know but
in that block of time a year could it
should might as well be just like 100
years apart because no one's like
congregating with each other because
it's just like we are two [ __ ]
different types of species right now
like you're a baby and you're a [ __ ]
adult i think fifth graders can play
with fourth graders
i don't know well i don't know maybe i'm
biased now because i just know what that
looks like and i'm like that's a baby
school like they have playgrounds with
[ __ ] sand in it when you go to fifth
grade there is no [ __ ] play box or
sand or any of that [ __ ] we had the
tetherball
and we had the handball and we had like
the handball like board and then we had
like the basketball so for me one
through four um the criteria was pretty
much like yours
um i didn't like boys though i didn't
like playing with boys i was very much a
girly girl did you have crushes already
a hundred percent i've had boyfriends
had crushes since kindergarten boy
friends did you hear that yeah and i
remember a time i think i was like in
first
grade
um i had a boyfriend and this other guy
liked me so they were both my boyfriends
and then they found out about each other
and then they would wrestle over me um
like in the sandbox and i was like ugh
this is so immature and
how
then
like
make you feel
like i was just like these guys
no i was just like oh they can't like
um i was i probably probably wouldn't be
able to be friends because i was so
judgmental but they're trying to like
show who's alpha to you and then i
thought it was and i thought it was so
childish i was just like
oh
yeah yeah i was really really girly
girly like i was super girly girly um
like i would collect stickers and stuff
and it wasn't until maybe
third or fourth grade when i really
started embracing my tomboy side and i
started playing more with boys and like
like
those lines were erased so it's like
same thing like if you wanted to have a
good time and you didn't care about
getting dirty and you were brave like
you needed to be brave like if kids were
going like i don't want to go into
bushes the devil lives in there i'd be
like
oh i want to be your friend you [ __ ]
you know so like i like [ __ ] like that
um but i mainly liked hanging around
with girls were you good at pe
we didn't have pe in fourth grade
in any of those classes you guys didn't
have to like run a mile or anything like
that no that wasn't until intermediate
what we call intermediate or middle
school damn we've been running miles
since uh
i'm sure i'm sure we had like play time
since fourth grade yeah like we had
recess right but you guys didn't have
like well like pe tests
like in in third grade like you know the
the last uh the last podcast what i was
talking about or a few episodes earlier
i was talking about when i first found
out i was good at something it was
because we were doing a pull-up test for
like second or third grade no i don't
think i had any of that i don't think it
was until i entered junior high
oh wow damn what somebody middle school
intermediate junior high those are like
it's i'm talking about the same wow yeah
i didn't have any of that it was just
fun fun time
um
and yeah i didn't like gossipy girls i
didn't like catty girls i remember there
was this [ __ ] catty-ass [ __ ] and she
didn't even [ __ ] speak english and
she was coming after me and i was like
[ __ ] but only spanish i went to
predominantly
spanish-speaking school oh um
yeah and i was just like ugh but you
don't even speak english how you judging
me yeah she's so mean i forgot her name
yeah but um but the criteria was mainly
female
or fun like a fun friend that was brave
oh and i also didn't like people that
didn't keep their word
oh
yeah
that's when i first would get my heart
broken
because it was kind of bar eraser i'm
not sure
and then like like the next day i'm like
have my eraser back i don't have any
more
annoying yeah i feel that you're
supposed to give it back to me i still
remember i'd lend someone uh hello so i
was really into hello kitty yeah like
fourth grade all the way up until i was
a full blown adult um
and i remember had this really cool
hello kitty pencil and i didn't like
sharing my pencils with anyone because
they were all like hello kitty and like
those like really cute ones like a
hirono pekko and [ __ ] oh my god i can't
remember and then like kiropi anyway
yeah oh my god
yeah he is yeah um
and then to have this crush on this guy
named eric and i had a crush on him for
years and then we finally got to be in a
class together and i was like ah i get
to stare at him all day
and he was probably
like in fifth or sixth grade i forget
maybe sixth grade and then he asked me
for a pencil and i'm like oh i don't
wanna share my pencils you have a crush
on them i know but i'm like but it's
eric and i was just fighting myself
cause i'm like no keep your pencils are
so cool no but it's eric and you like
him so much and i'm like oh you're right
i was like fine i'll give him my
prettiest one i'm like here you go you
could borrow it
he could borrow it right yeah
and he never gave it back yeah eric give
me back my goddamn pencil
he never gave it back and then i asked
him for it the next day he goes i don't
have it anymore
he probably gave it to his crush that's
that's look what i got you yeah that's
what i mean at my dime when i was a kid
if you don't hold your word
man i'm like maybe that's why like gangs
are so attractive you know
because like
it's kind of like i love the way you
enter a conversation it's only it's only
it's only
the stuff that you care about
right so all i cared about is accepting
people
if you're down
if you keep your word and those are
literally like the three most important
principles in becoming a gangster yeah
but that's also how
you create your friend circles too it's
the same thing but no one holds they're
not your friends no no one holds it to
the level that gangs hold it
right
imagine i don't know i've never been in
a game backstab someone in the game oh
yeah you're dead you're getting [ __ ]
jumped yeah right in a regular like
kettlebell team like no one's jumping
her ass well i mean it's a tetherball
team no one jumps anyone there exactly
exactly so because of that the
consequences are so big people really
care versus like in regular elementary
school the kid that borrowed my pencil
or whatever my eraser never gave it back
and i'm like man that's like a [ __ ]
shady [ __ ]
if there were tetherball teams and i
don't know if there are so i'm super
ignorant to this topic
if there were right now yes as an adult
and you were gonna create your own play
that's not even what i was gonna ask
dude um how would you what would the
uniforms look like are they more like on
the tennis side like short shorts
like a little zipper jack
oh oh warm-ups
no it'd be like like compression pants
and compression top really yeah like
some [ __ ] tron [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
oh
that's [ __ ] weird maybe it's
sleeveless you could show buff arms
i just picture the most [ __ ] puny
[ __ ] people for some odd reason but
of course not because fitness has
evolved so much every [ __ ] yolks
either that or baseball outfits
why
talk [ __ ] about baseball players
because it kind of like swing to
that's not at all how you swing a bat
dude i mean you're not [ __ ] trying to
this is this is a gang swing
no you're [ __ ] you're swinging you're
doing something no that's a baseball
swing the other one was a [ __ ] i'm
gonna trash your car or like bash your
head with this bat oh fine yeah okay
anyway uh so that was my criteria for
like middle school i mean uh elementary
school yeah that was mine too that's why
i think gangs are so attractive
uh not anymore though right because just
there's too many consequences
uh i still hold
dear to those three yeah you do so now
it's either
i have friends that are like that
or i have people
that live by this whether they're in a
gang or not but i really vibe with them
fine okay next phase in life next phase
in life
um probably like high school or whatever
still very similar those three
i um
like one of my closest friends that i
made in
um high school his name is ray
and he was really cool because uh so by
the time i got to my final destination
in high school i've already been to
three
right so i would say i'm a pretty well
traveled high schooler you are yeah yeah
like if i had a lot of stamps in the
high school passport i sure do and um
and so i've experienced a lot i've like
banged a little bit i've raved a little
bit sold pharmaceuticals a little bit
um you're so you're so well traveled
i've been uh on a varsity sports team a
little bit so i've done a little bit you
know and then so because of that like
i felt like my acceptance and uh
maturity was a lot higher than a lot of
the people in my high school because
they're still playing those stupid ass
high school games you know
some i do like some adults don't play
those [ __ ] high schools yeah i'm like
i'm like bro no matter how cool you are
or you think you are
in about six months we gonna find out
like six months cause we're gonna
graduate i see we're gonna find out how
cool you really are in the real world
you know you might have the coolest
haircut right now
but once fools go to like a legit
college or get a legit job and they
start making real piper
piper i'm like
how long
do you know
how cool is that that little haircut
gonna
last you you know yeah
this episode of get close is brought to
you by zip recruiter i am so
excited for summer because summer time
means family trips
and trips mean i get to meet a lot of
cool people that can really make our
vacations come to life like when you go
to the hotel and their concierge who
knows of the best places to go like
they're really familiar with all the
local eats or if you have a tour guide
with great stories like all the stories
you can't get in a history book or when
you go to a restaurant and the server
knows the ins and outs of the menu and
can make amazing recommendations based
off the mood you're in you know
outstanding talent is crucial for
successful businesses and if you're
hiring you can find talent for roles
like these and more at
ziprecruiter.com and you can try it for
free at
ziprecruiter.com
get close these are really powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job and you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply so whether you have a big
business you need to expand your team or
this is your first time as an
entrepreneur or even freelancer and you
need extra help i highly recommend
ziprecruiter because you can find the
perfect person that you need and on the
flip side if you're top qualified talent
people are always looking to add people
like you to their team so make sure you
go check it out go to ziprecruiter.com
get close that's ziprecruiter.com get
close and that's where you can try
ziprecruiter for free
and um
so what i liked about my homie ray is
because i went to so many high schools i
almost had to like start my friend's
circle all over every time from scratch
you know and i think one cool thing
about that is um the sad thing is it's
really hard to have long-term
friendships
the cool thing is you're able to kind of
reinvent yourself every single time
right
so by the time i came to um my last year
mark keppel
um
i was like you know i'm just just do me
i'm gonna just do what i think what were
you doing before
uh you know like
the the younger you are the more you
still care about social
your social hierarchy type stuff okay
yeah you know so like for example if
school's not cool
then you're gonna ditch or it's gonna be
the loser that's that goes to school you
know or if like everyone has like a car
and you don't have one everyone's like
oh i'm gonna try to get a job and work
and or do whatever so i can have it so
you're still trying to get those cool
points right yeah because you want you
want the acceptance from your peers
right
so by the time i was my my senior year
i've done so many things i was like man
i don't really give a [ __ ] i'm just
going to do what i like what i think i
need
to
um get into my next phase of life when i
graduate
so when i came back to marketplace time
i was like you know what i'm uh i'm
gonna sign up for weight training
because i really like weights
and i'm also gonna join the asb
because i feel like um with someone like
me not some goodie two shoes that
student i think maybe i could really
make a difference or i can be more of
like an outreach to um the more of the
school like really get the school
involved in things that cause i always
hear asb [ __ ] and as wack as it sounds
i'm like a lot of these things are
pretty cool
so i'm like i'm gonna try to like get
the school involved or whatever yeah
cause back in the day school like if you
were into school you were a [ __ ] nerd
you're a nerd you're [ __ ] geeky yeah
i don't know it sounds like now it's
actually really nice and it's really
positive yeah especially to go to a good
school yeah you know so yeah i signed up
for weight training and in weight
training i met this dude named ray
and ray was cool he uh
the first time he came in so he he
dressed like a cholo um
and when he first came in
he came in on heelys
so that already sounds [ __ ] wack
exactly which i thought was dope because
if you went to mark keppel at that time
it everyone dressed like blood and blood
out i see er like that school looks like
um
like you go to lunch time and you can
see okay asian boys is here uh black
dragon's there there viet boyz is here
um like belle garden king cobras are
there like you could just see all the
game like everyone's like just
almost like a like like west side story
like visually you can see like who like
the clicks you know 18 streets over
there sangra is over here like you just
see all these like
gangs all over right half mexican half
asian and it's the breeding ground of
some of the biggest sgv games back then
and that's what you see so it's very
like that so it's very machismo
everyone's wearing big white tees cortez
chucks dickies that kind of that whole
thing right
and uh then you have a occasional like
skater they got kids that like pacsun
the people right now your school was
gnarly occasional sprinkle a little bit
of like people into punk you know the
people that have like the safety pins on
their clothes like that kind of stuff
and then so when you have a dude like
raymond
when he just rides into weight training
with heelys on it caught my eye
i was like dude
this [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
either what the [ __ ]
and then i was like well usually when
you don't give a [ __ ] it's of two
reasons one you really don't give a [ __ ]
or two you ain't got no friends
so it's just so weird yeah so it's one
of the other two you know
and then
so i started lifting
he joins in with me because i train with
him like sure he started lifting him oh
damn this guy's pretty strong and we
just start talking and chatting it up
and then uh then he starts telling me
about how like hey there's this he's
like if you like my shoes um there's a
shoe store down the street they're like
nah dawg like every every thursday they
have this contest like if you put them
on and you can ride them they'll give
you a free pair
and i'm like dance guys really really
open about like whack [ __ ]
and then uh oh my god another man this
guy's coming this guy is really
oblivious oh this guy's kind of cool you
know
and then so because i had a few other
friends
uh from before that went there i would
ask about him i'm like hey do you know
anything about him to get like to get a
co-sign whatever and everyone that i
knew they're like oh him oh dude that
fool used to be with asian boys to do
this whatever [ __ ] i was like oh [ __ ]
this is my kind of peeps like he's done
that stuff he's kind of like me he's
done all that he's over it he thinks
he's [ __ ] stupid so he's just doing
him like i'm doing me
so we became really really tight that
year
and then we ended up like we would go
like tempur-pedic mattress shopping
together like just stuff that we can you
guys are all like married
no we're just like i don't know
it was just like shout outs for [ __ ]
mattresses in high school no because you
would see those infomercials our matches
would just like for me my masters just
showed up no we we didn't we was there
when i was born we didn't go buy it we
couldn't afford it oh
you guys just went to [ __ ] around no
because like you know like everyone has
that inner scientist right
so sure so for us like we would see
those commercials
where like there's a wine glass and
drive a bowling ball and it wouldn't
move were you guys high no oh so we were
just like
it was just cool to be able to shed that
like
[ __ ] yeah my thug nature whatever i
gotta shed that and so we're just me and
him so we would uh do that or we would
like try to see if we could like race
each other in shopping carts you know we
just became like like really close uh
friends in that way how cute
cool and cute
i was gonna say cool
yeah and it was uh yeah it was it was
really really cool to be like oh man
there's another person like that and
then so when i ended up joining asb
he joined it with me he's like oh cool
i'm down to try that [ __ ] out how cute
just another one little quick story
about raymond that i thought was [ __ ]
dope because i'm not really from the 66
at that point at that point i've only
been there for like four or five years
um
i've heard stories about him
but you don't know it until you're in
action yeah right
so
um i was in dr uh involved in a
pharmaceutical transaction
um
uh with the initials hs
um
you make it sound like you haven't
talked about all this [ __ ] everywhere
no i don't know okay i don't know if i
have so with the pharmaceutical
transaction with with an organization
with the name hs
and then if you're from the sgv are
trying to tell you know what i'm talking
about
and uh it goes it goes wrong it goes
wrong and they think uh i owe them money
or they think i owe them a deal but they
owe me money i forgot what it was but
i'm so low at this so i'm not being with
nobody
and i go
we go to a rave at night three of those
fools catch me there
they're like hey what's up you know and
then i'm like let's go outside then
because i'm like let's just [ __ ]
i don't like to talk very much i'm not a
very big talker i'm like let's just go
there it's either i'm gonna kill you or
you're gonna kill me that's it
right and then uh
and there's three of them raymond i
don't know what the hell he was doing is
probably [ __ ]
checking out tempur-pedic mattresses or
something
had a rave i don't know dude [ __ ]
black light painting i don't know
whatever rave activities he is he's
curious right we're both curious people
we're both inner scientists so he's
doing his scientist [ __ ] i'm trying to
do my scientific [ __ ] but i got caught
up with these
three uh
organizers so we we go uh as we're
walking outside of the club
raymond comes out and he goes what's
going on over here
and then i uh i go oh they think i owe a
money or a moment or whatever the hell
it is and then um raymond looks at those
three
and he goes it's done all right
and then those three dudes were like
all right it's done
just like that
and i was like oh [ __ ] oh my damn this
will does come
from like a lineage of a long time of
doing things you know like he's not even
from their old gang or anything like
that it's just they've been in the same
hood
long enough to know like who can pull
what yeah and what can happen because
i'm new right because i grew up in
cerritos i would have been so oblivious
if i saw you walking out with those
three guys and stuff i would have been
like oh my bad you're busy and i'd walk
back because he recognized me
like i said it was like west side story
right like you just saw people yeah and
you knew their association you just you
just knew and you've seen each other so
much and like you know like i'm so not
street smart i'd be like oh my bad i'm
interrupting i'll be inside so you're
probably like no i need to you see four
four bald headed cholos and they're all
wearing white tees
you don't go
oh i think they're like no i'm [ __ ]
oblivious i didn't i grew up in the
[ __ ] hood right but like were so far
removed from it that i'd just be like oh
okay they're just talking about
something yeah yeah
raymond just said
squash it
and then we just squashed it did you
ever talk about it then like like hey
what was that about like did you guys
ever catch up on it um
a little bit so i was like oh yo you
know those guys he goes yeah he likes to
punk the [ __ ] out of him in junior high
so i was like oh okay so it's high
school now but people still remember and
you know there is a pecking order and
these organizations and stuff so even
though like raymond isn't from there
anymore it's it's uh
there's there's a lot of interpersonal
relationships for sure yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i was like oh [ __ ] that's dope
because it was cool i was ready to do it
i don't care you know and then but it
was just cool for him to come in and do
that i don't know that's dope man it's
looking out man yeah yeah that is sweet
yeah so like that's all i really cared
about so by my senior year
all my friends were
down like for anything and very
accepting which is why i like i even
talked about like the whole peacemakers
thing
on david's podcast
because we're trying to do good like
we're a bunch of like just just
hooligans hooligans
doing good in our own way so
you know try to like spread the word of
good while smoking cigarettes and then
um
uh what is it called yeah just not being
too judgmental yeah that's like all i
really
really cared about yeah and loyalty
for me in high school um
i don't know if i cared about loyalty
maybe i did i don't know i don't know if
i have it as like filed away the way you
do like where it's like a thing but i
was so sheltered and i was so controlled
by my parents that as soon as i got into
high school i was like
i'm doing me [ __ ] all that
so like my grades started plummeting
like i just wanted to hang out with fun
people like i didn't want to hang out
with like studious [ __ ] geeky what i
considered kiki of like let's play
[ __ ] cook to let's do like little
pokemon like i wanted to be like a
badass like i wanted to get in trouble i
wanted to try all the things how come
you didn't like
like join a gang or something
cause i thought they were stupid
what kind of what
i did but like i just thought like well
not like in real trouble like to take me
to jail trouble like trouble with my
parents trouble
oh like i just wanted to rebel against
them like little warm trouble yeah yeah
yeah like i'm not trying to [ __ ]
catch a case or nothing you know what i
mean
i don't know because
i remember i first heard like one of my
friend's friends steal a car and i'm
like oh he's cool
he's cool no i would have been like what
a [ __ ] loser and i'm like and the
cops are after him
the cops know about him
really it was a heartthrob
[Laughter]
oh my oh my god tell me more
andy has a house arrest bracelet on his
ankle
oh my god oh so [ __ ] wet
oh my god no not at all i thought that
was loser behavior like i still wanted
to succeed i wanted to succeed in life
but on my own terms i see so i was
definitely in a rebellion phase
so i only wanted to hang out with chicks
that were like that i only wanted to
hang out with chicks that were
opinionated that like my best friend in
high school was 5 uh 4 11 okay i'm
probably already 5 11 in high school we
called her polly pocket because she's so
tiny and petite and like her wrists were
literally like
little bird wrists and her name's paulie
too no her name was veronica um but we
would call her everyone knew her as
polly you know she's like this fiery ass
like you don't [ __ ] with her like she
will [ __ ] you up type of chick you know
and those were the girls that like i
loved so all my girl crew were just
tough [ __ ] like that like like oh
you're gonna [ __ ] with me i'm gonna [ __ ]
with you you type [ __ ] you know but they
weren't like
gangster or anything like that it was
more like hey we're just doing our own
[ __ ]
y'all like y'all so like we all kind of
like went in all of like the different
circles like we would um hang out with
like the jocks or like the popular or
like the [ __ ] stoner crew or the
skater crew and it wasn't as like
gang infested as yours sounded we
definitely had that and there was
definitely
like in the 2000s there was like the
thick of like uh we were in the thick of
like um
the mexican and asian like rivalry so
there were like a bunch of school fights
that would happen but like
it wasn't the majority they were
definitely the minori minority or at
least i
from my [ __ ] point of view right
because remember i would probably see
you walking out with three bald headed
dudes and oversized clothes and i'd be
like oh you guys are busy without really
knowing so that's just my scooter do you
guys have rumbles like happening in the
cafeteria like yeah we did weekly not
weekly but we definitely had like maybe
one once once a month
yeah ours was like weeks i remember like
there was one year though maybe even
daily if i went to school more um where
it did happen quite a bit
but like where like food's flying people
just getting yeah but not like maybe i
could i could probably recall like maybe
like two times where that happened did
you guys have cops on campus
yeah like actual like like no no no no
no no okay yeah we had actual cops on
campus because it happened so much no we
didn't so i just had school security so
yeah the school security couldn't really
do too much oh [ __ ] no i wasn't like
that people didn't get arrested
and i heard kepler wasn't even the worst
one in the sgv i heard uh san gabriel is
actually the worst worst one really yeah
that's like because you know like when
kids get in trouble they get sent to
other schools yeah for some reason they
all end up like going to um they all get
to get sent to san gabriel before you go
to continuation school yeah no it wasn't
like that so my criteria was like
um i just wanted you to be down and have
fun
to like
stick up for yourself like not take any
[ __ ] from anyone
and um
i think that's all i really cared about
i just wanted to have fun i just wanted
to be with rule breakers but like like
the line stepper rules what made you
want to be a rule breaker
because i was just i just had so many
rules on me where i'm like
[ __ ] man i just need to breathe a bit
like i just want i want people that test
the line and ride the line did you have
any um
what about rule breaker in terms of
success did you did you guys have it not
there yet i wasn't there yet did you
guys have anyone that was like
outstanding at your high school
of course
and i wanted nothing to do with those
people
yeah i've always been interested in them
yeah i was just like
um
i was just so deprived of social
interaction that that's all i wanted
and then my girlfriends um they couldn't
be like those hoochie like loose chicks
like i didn't want to do i don't want
anything to do with that like if you had
like a reputation of being like that or
like being boy crazy i was like nah you
ain't you ain't it like i ain't trying
to be your friend
um so like my friend crew was always
like the like the [ __ ]
hot [ __ ] you know what i mean i i
think back to like hoochie chicks
and i think i was so oblivious that i
don't even realize they were coming on
to me until now
i remember this one time i was in uh
i was sitting in the office
and these this chick comes up to me and
then like we're just talking and i don't
know where she tells me she's been
shaving her vagina and then how it's
like really itchy growing back
she's not hitting on you she's telling
you that you're a homie and then she
asks me if i want to see it yeah you're
a homie
you sure yeah she's not hitting on you
that's the last thing that's the last
thing a chick wants you to see because
it's not attractive
nah i think she wanted me to see it and
then we could go to the bathroom and
then and then uh that's a weird come on
maybe asian people do it different no
she was white
was she yeah you swear then we can go to
maybe white people do it differently go
to alice in wonderland
go down the rabbit hole that's what she
said no i'm just making that up what
part did what part did you make up
goddammit just the alice in one part oh
yeah i don't think she's coming on to
you
because that's embarrassing for girls
at least in that age i think white
chicks operate differently maybe i think
i can't speak for it was coming on i
think she was coming on to me but i was
so ridiculous that i was just like you
were so ridiculous or is that the
statement was ridiculous i'm i'm i'm uh
what's going on i was talking a little
bit i was too recorded
i see where i was like um yeah you are
stupid still yeah i was like
oh itches that must suck
i probably stopped it right there
i'm like damn i feel bad do you are you
embarrassed for yourself at that age are
you like man you're so stupid no i don't
know until later i know
looking back at it right now are you
embarrassed of that
um a little bit i think
i'm embarrassed but i also didn't have
too many interactions so i don't even
know what's happening but there's a lot
of missed opportunity i guess
what a weird come on if it is a come on
i don't know any girl that's like oh it
comes like so itchy i really think she
thought you just you think a 15 year old
has game or 16 year old has game [ __ ]
yeah i was thinking of game a long time
ago dude okay that's the last thing i
would want i'm pretty sure i'm pretty
sure she was coming on to me no i don't
know well maybe
if you say so but yeah so that was like
my
my thing like my girl crew
um and i had guys in our crew too but
even the guys like they couldn't be
flirty with us like i'm like then you're
not a homie you know what i mean like i
didn't like any guys like that everyone
had to be friend-zoned we were super
homies like super duper homies um and
they were like there was like a big
group of us that were like that and we
would always hang out there was at least
at any given time like you know how
friends kind of rotate it in and out
there was always at least seven of us
minimum um where we would just all hang
out all the time
and um when you say you hang out all the
time you mean only at school yeah and
then like if my mom would let me go out
and stuff then we would all meet up at
like someone's house oh that's pretty
cool yeah yeah and we'd like if any if
if like they always hung out but when i
was able to hang out with them it was
always the same people so it's always
super fun i see i've always been
attracted to outstanding people but um i
think my own
social
pressures got in my way
i think for me the outstanding thing was
morals
like i think when i felt like people had
like really righteous morals that's when
i was like dope you're above like i just
felt like a lot of people were super
animalistic
like they were all like at least in that
age range i just felt like they only
cared about hooking up
and like having a boyfriend and they
just cared about that [ __ ] you know
or like going to this party or like this
gossipy [ __ ] and i just never felt like
i really rely but belonged uh like i
never really belonged in that so if you
were
the
counter of that then i was like oh i'm
very intrigued by you i see yeah
yeah i think for
i mean that's kind of like gangs too
right like you have you have a few rules
but those rules mean a lot
so that's what attracted me to
you know people like that
um but there were people that were like
someone was i think on the um like us
badminton team
and i was like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] as
a high school that's [ __ ] crazy
you know so stuff like that would really
intrigue me
it makes sense you grew up with a lot of
like accolades being kind of like i'm so
like
oh that's so whack and so i wouldn't
even like try to like get to know them
or anything like that but like yeah i
would hear stuff like that you know or
like i remember some kid was like in
mensa or some [ __ ] you know that genius
whatever i think just like which is
interesting because mensah in like
spanish means like dumb girl
yeah so just like
like uh yeah just outstanding people was
very very almost like you know how like
on
social media today right when someone's
really good at something like it
attracts the attention of lots of people
yeah um
maybe surface level attention yeah
because i don't know how many people are
actually really trying to like
like the amount of people that know
garyvee versus the amount of people that
take his classes are like it's probably
way smaller yeah but for me like i would
really be interested not just like know
of them i really want to know like
how they did that
but um i
i never uh
pursued it because i just thought it was
so whack yeah
i think for me it was more like
righteous morally like righteous people
that i was just like whoa
i guess i wasn't really around it very
much or maybe i was with like my parents
i don't know i don't know where it came
from but i just always saw that as such
a huge thing
like if you were able to stick to what
you say
and live by that and i was like whoa
that is [ __ ] cool
like i thought that was rad my first
taste of uh outstanding people
is um
i think i was probably like six or seven
and these kids are probably nine or ten
and they're these two korean twins
and they played hockey
and they trained every day like in our
on our street like they would set up
cones
and they'd go on their own no parents oh
[ __ ] they would like as soon as one guy
finishes the cones the other comes back
the other one goes back the other comes
back well maybe they got threatened to
go do it by the parents and they're like
i'm not gonna watch it and then uh every
morning at least they didn't [ __ ] around
which is that every morning and night uh
they would sprint on their rollerblades
with uh dragging a tire behind them
it's up and down and they must have been
[ __ ] fast yeah just they play ice
hockey you know so they're just like
training they're just training hard hard
hard yeah i think that was the first
time where i was like
and then i found out i think uh
they were like some of the best in the
city league or something like that and
then i think that's my first taste of
like [ __ ] if you want something you want
to be good at something you really have
to get after it like doing things
recreationally isn't going to get you
very far wow that's cool that you
connected the dots that fast well i just
see them i just go like wow these guys
like because we all play street hockey
on that street no one looked like that
no i think they were the um
they were probably like the influencers
you know or like the culture creators on
our street and it's one it's the one
we're picking teams if like let's say we
already have a team going and uh i think
one of them's name was dennis i think
dennis and danny i think if dennis and
danny like came back home from school
and if they're willing to jump in like
you're more row for your team which is
like oh yeah we're gonna win [ __ ] yeah
you know
it was like is worth having one of them
on then one of our friend's dads that's
how good they were yeah and you know
adults are generally better at kids at
anything not really
some adults are [ __ ] they have two
left feet or they're hella stiff don't
move you have an athletic dad got it so
one of our friends has the athletic dad
and so if you were to jump in you're
happy too because he's probably like six
something you know but then when dennis
or danny jumped in you're like oh we're
gonna win this [ __ ]
yeah so that was that was my standard
for um high school and it was pretty
similar when i went to college it was
the same thing like i just liked really
righteous people i just like people with
like really strong morals um but now it
started shifting because now i had more
goals in front of my face where i'm like
i need to go to college i needed like i
just knew what phases i needed to
achieve
and if they weren't going down that path
then i'm like oh we can't be friends i
don't really have any friends in college
yeah that's what i ended up happening to
do yeah cause i think like one thing
that i held on to
um so i think you know like as you're a
kid you add layers of like
prerequisites yeah criteria right
so in the beginning it's just acceptance
acceptance don't make fun of people just
want to have fun
then it becomes those two acceptance
have fun and then loyalty like that was
something that was huge in like the gang
days right or especially if you grow up
in the hood like if someone gives you
their word and they keep it like oh man
this guy's dope
because it also means they got your back
no matter what yeah you know
um
and then so you have these three things
these three things are still important
to me then you take those three things
and once you get into college it's about
goals and your aspirations and stuff
yeah it almost feels like those become
two different worlds
you know like
i get that like when i meet people with
big goals yeah like loyalty is not that
big of a thing or their own way yeah you
get it yeah because now it's almost like
they're loyal to their goals yeah
because now you're like dude i got
[ __ ] jumped in the bathroom where the
[ __ ] where are you achieving my goals
i'm not gonna go to jail for you yeah
i'm i'm trying to become a doctor yeah
and i'm like what the [ __ ] you spying on
this ass [ __ ] you know so it
almost feels like it's like it has to be
going this way yeah so i think because
of that i think i had my own um
not identity crisis but my own like [ __ ]
who are my friends from my friends
turmoil yeah my inner turmoil so i ended
up having my friends that i met in high
school
that satisfied like one part of me yeah
but once going to ucla
i didn't really make any meaningful
friendships my time there yeah because
no one there
um
possessed those other three important
things that were so important to me
growing up yeah and that's fair i think
that's um
yeah i think that's a good balance too
because how rare is it like that's
probably why you're only gonna have
remember like when we were younger they
would like i would i remember hearing
this in movies or in books or just other
like older people saying it like
once you get older you could be you're
going to be able to count like your best
friends on one hand and still have
fingers left over and i was like yeah
cause you wack yeah you got seven
fingers
you know because i was just like because
you probably have problems but it's so
true because i think that's what ends up
happening you know like
life changes people or like your things
that you want are so unique to you that
like it reduces the amount of people
that can like fit into this like very
unique
you know set of standards that you have
which is why um i think when we ended up
meeting david
he became so [ __ ] tight with us
because uh the first time we met at the
san diego asian film festival
we realized it was actually
those three things because me and joe
are like from the same area right so we
obviously have those three things yeah
our goals are the same i'm trying to
build jk so out of all my friends if
there was four check boxes he was the
only one that hit all four like that
yeah yeah right so it was just me that
have all four joe has all those all four
and then throughout my entire college
never met
anyone else that had all four maybe they
had two out of the four or three out of
the four but not four out of four
david was the next person in
my life
when we would go out to eat afterwards
and we would like
we're like man look at those [ __ ]
chauncey ass
we're like we saw things the same way
we talked about like our upbringing the
same way like from his stories i could
tell how big loyalty means to him and he
could tell obviously how big loyalty
means
to joe you know like
like just all the stuff that we went
through
and uh but also we're
both
trying to make it on youtube so it's not
that we had small goals so when you have
small goals it's easy to hold on to my
loyalty you know it's like oh boys for
life type of thing when you got big
goals there's going to be a lot of
situations that that should yeah you're
questioned you're you're getting [ __ ]
it's pulling it apart you know you're
being questioned
um
even like in the famous like super bad
movie right like michael sarah like big
school jonah hill's like yo what's up i
thought we're boys even like something
as small as that it gets your
relationship gets tested and with david
it was like right off the bat we just
knew you know was love at first sight
yeah it was it's very rare it's very
rare to like um
to to meet people like that yeah that's
super cute yeah yeah and the more i'm
talking this out with you right now i'm
going [ __ ] i think i've carried that
righteousness and moral
um so like i i love righteousness i love
the the
morals like the high morals and
obviously loyalty and stuff like that is
a given for me but i don't know if it's
as strong as like the gang part of it
but it's definitely huge you don't have
to be in a gang like david always says
like he was never in a gang but he hung
around them so if you hung around them
and you saw consequences for actions you
understood what's important got it
um
yet enough loyalty was that strong to me
because i think i started seeing maybe
it comes from myself too that like
people just change
and like you have to like you can't like
you don't possess people you know what i
mean
so like they're gonna be
they should be allowed to
do what they want to do
and if that doesn't align with what you
considered
how you wanted them to either resolve
the situation or handle that situation
or like um like um
like respond to things then that was a
marker for me to be like oh okay we
don't see things that i you gotta go
yeah but i think like when you're true
homies you guys talk it out true like
you don't let the action
create friction yeah and then go what do
we do about this friction true very true
yeah i'm very big on that actually yeah
it's very big it's more like um that's
true i take it back you're right i am
very big on that um because for me like
you always want to have your friends
back you know no matter what and then at
the like when some [ __ ] does pop off you
assume the best and then question and go
hey like this seemed out of character
what's going on yeah i'm very much like
that okay i take that yeah like you talk
it through so that
um you understand that it's not loyalty
thing yeah you know very true you you
make sure the loyalty is there but you
go but for our own personal growth we
have to do this or that and then you
talk it out the whole way through or at
least you try to find a way to make all
parties feel comfortable yeah i think
that's where the righteousness comes for
me
like you need to be a righteous person
to be able to like
even have that
conversation so i think that's why for
me it like
in the righteous part of things it like
it
it needs to be in there but i guess it
is loyalty
yeah and i think i carried those things
with me
up until now
also also with business so i haven't
done as much business as you um and i
haven't done a lot of business with
people outside of our friend circle you
know
um the closest one would probably be
like our current situation with one of
our partners and stuff but um
yeah like
moving forward in a business
relationship
i would obviously look for morals and
righteousness still that's always going
to be a thing for me
but i don't know if i really care to be
friends or not like obviously you want
to be able to like
gel
right because you need to be able to
build but i don't know if like i want us
to be super tight i don't know if that's
one of the criteria's that i need
like i just want them to bring a skill
that i don't possess
i see yeah yeah um
i think business itself it's a long
journey
because like it's
i also realize um at least through my
own business journey
or your own relationship journey
actually
every relationship that
you get into you could only base it off
the last
of course right so you first have
friends you know okay cool friends is
like this this is what i like about
friends
so now when you have like a romantic
partner you're like oh i want my
romantic partner to be like this plus
this layer
you know and it's just we [ __ ] plus
we [ __ ] and we like read poems to
each other and [ __ ]
and then someone read me poems i'll read
your palms
roses are red what no [ __ ] me [ __ ] you
woo hoo okay fine did that even rhyme
you know and then um with uh like with
joe when we first got into business
together with jk it was like oh man
like it's the friendship and then
let's let's
build something bigger than us two out
of it you know so every single phase
that's rare you know how rare that is
what
like don't they always say like don't go
into business with friends or family
because just there's so many layers i
completely disagreed and then now i'm
getting closer and closer to agreeing
yeah in the beginning i was like what
are you talking about because it's like
me and joe are tight and then we're
friends and we could balance friendship
we could balance business we could talk
things out yeah we
almost never blame anything on each
other you guys are actually [ __ ] rare
and we're super down to try new [ __ ]
with each other yeah and when one of us
is slacking the other one is down to
pick up the slime without talking [ __ ]
i've seen you i've never seen you guys
argue and [ __ ] yeah or yell at each
other
you know on both sides yeah
you guys are [ __ ] there but then i
realized
it's really rare like that so [ __ ]
rare yeah because like friendship
it's it's it's like that french
friendship dynamic works because it
doesn't have all these other stressors
that it doesn't need to have yeah you
know that's why like even like us
being married a couple and then building
businesses is also is also [ __ ] rare
because it like it adds so many
unnecessary stressors to both
relationships yeah even this even
something as small as my dad that's what
my dad told me when i was like when i
first started going out with my friends
he's like don't ever borrow money from
friends and don't ever lend your friends
or if you land your friend money yeah
don't ever ask it back yeah he goes
accounting
is gonna be the biggest friendship like
killer yeah so that's not even business
yet yeah you know but just the minute
you start throwing numbers back and
forth like let's say you go eat oh can
you can you spot me and then later on uh
you spot me and then one person
remembers they spot it three times the
other person feels like they only did it
once it already starts causing a riff
yeah and and one person's mind like oh
that guy's always like trying to nickel
and dime me but the other person does it
and then he started already causing a
riff yeah so my dad's always like don't
ever borrow money and if someone wants
to borrow money just pretend like you
just after you gave it so they don't owe
you anything back yeah
and then um so even something as small
as that
not gnarly yeah relationships are
complicated man they're so complicated
and and i actually really do love
relationships i love learning about
people i love learning just like the
behaviors and just the things that we do
when you know stressors are involved
it's very fascinating i shouldn't say i
love it it's very fascinating to me
um but they're so [ __ ] hard
they're [ __ ] hard and i don't know if
they're hard because maybe i don't
understand them or if they're hard
because um they're just hard they're
hard
the tv you don't understand them either
you know she's telling you about her
[ __ ] itchy [ __ ]
yeah they're hard because the two
biggest lessons i learned
in business and friendship is um
when it comes to
uh
being friends first or including friends
in your business
when you act on convenience
or romance like oh romanticize this
would be so cool it's usually the worst
decision you're right because what ends
up happening is instead of objectively
looking at does this person fit this
role myself included
it's more like rose-colored glasses yeah
it's like oh man this person is wrong
like oh this person cooks so good they
should for sure run the kitchen versus
wait have you ever ran a kitchen staff
you know it's like
you're like it's
everything is like in rose-colored
glasses and it doesn't fit the right way
and then that's with zero problems
and the minute you have business it's
speed bump after speed bump after speed
bump and that causes big risks
especially if expectations aren't met on
both sides
so there's that the second thing is um
people's life cycles right right like um
when
when me and joe started jk
a million bucks i bet neither of us were
even considering what workflow would
look like when one of us have a kid yep
right and then so someone as dope as joe
when we had taika and i'm like hey i'm
gonna be out for a month
no problem i get it this covers me right
never goes dude that whole month or two
you're out of jk news it was so hard
without you or whatever right you're
just done
and uh
people get married like people have
their own life cycles that will also
like pull you away from joint ventures
and stuff and like even uh like in next
month
joe's gonna be in hawaii for a whole
month doing his whole june b thing
i get it that's what he wants to do yeah
but it's rare so i don't i don't like
hold it above him or nothing like that
that's what he's gonna go do i'll rock
with him i'm gonna support him i'll even
try to go hawaii if i can for his grand
opening
um but yeah like i realized
that type of uh relationship where both
sides aren't really keeping tabs is
really rare it's really really rare so
because of that i think if i were to
start another business from scratch
i would have the first thing i would do
is
figure out what the business needs on
paper yeah
and then find the most qualified
personnel yep and then i think
friendships built through
victories yeah
are actually like a merit-based
friendship sports team yeah that
actually has holds more meaning like do
we want four nba championships together
that holds way more meaning
then
hey can you can you draft this guy from
this team meet him our best bud since
high school and you guys lose or win or
do whatever but then uh that is a very
fleeting type of friendship yeah you
know because there's so many other
factors involved yeah very true very
insightful man
i mean it's interesting and i and i do
enjoy it and i sigh because it's like
dang right like i fee i hear all of my
like
uh parents and uncles and aunts going
like man if i knew then would i know now
type of thing right so that's where the
site comes from but i'm i'm definitely
grateful for all the experiences that
i've had i'm grateful for all the people
that i've met because literally every
single person that i've met good or bad
interaction they have built me
right because i'm a product of everyone
that i encounter right and every person
you meet is going to teach you something
about yourself that you didn't know
whether it's good or bad right so i'm
very grateful for everything that i've
experienced up until this point and i
like i'm like yes i needed to go through
whatever i needed to go through good or
bad um
and and i look forward to what the next
phase in our life whether that's in our
relationship or our friendships or you
know business is going to take me
because i'm like damn i'm about to learn
more [ __ ] and it's exciting to me
yeah i remember as a kid going like why
would anyone ever want to be alone
i wanna
i wanna i never wanna be alone i wanna
be with my friends 24 7. like if me and
my best friend could wear the same
onesie that's cute i remember that too
you know imagine we found out we were
actually related yeah like that you know
and then you go through so much life
that like the the older you meet people
they're like
alone time
is awesome yep we get it we get it and
on that note i want to wrap it up and
say thank you so much to everyone that's
uh supported us and listened to this
podcast you mean the world to us thank
you so much always always always uh hit
us up about any topic that you feel like
we should be talking about or that you
want us to cover you can reach us at
bart quan on instagram or geo underscore
antoinette on instagram or leave it you
know in the comments um but yeah until
next time see you later bye